do you believe that love is real
completely completely and artly
everything I say all the things I've
just said which they're going to attack
me for and call me a misogynist for and
say I'm hateful for I actually come from
a place of love comes from a place of
love because I think that women are
happier if they act in a certain way
which is true to their National
biological imperatives and true to God I
think that men treat women who act true
to God better I think that their
relationships are better I think the
family is better I think the children
are raised better I think Society ends
up better I think as a whole all of it
the whole world becomes a better place
and it's all based on love I truly and
hardly believe in love between a man and
a woman but I'm not going to love a girl
who can't keep her legs closed what
about what about unconditional love does
that exist no it does for women it
doesn't exist for men why does mother
love their sons unconditionally right
women women can be unconditionally loved
by society as a whole no matter how bad
it is a thing women do if she's pretty
bro a woman could go and kill 10 people
but if she was smoking hot and her mug
shot came up it would be all over
Twitter kill me anytime babe
you've seen the the hot criminals they
think oh yeah Jeffrey Dahmer is like
idolized and Jeffrey Dahmer is getting
more DMS than me and he's dead
traditionally loved men are only loved
for how useful we are second you stop
being useful as a man you'll see how
cruel this world is when nobody looks at
you and goes this man has a utility this
man is good for X this man can solve
this problem second you become a useless
man you'll see how cold and heartless
this world is because nobody gives a
solitary [__] about men who can't fix
problems true that's why we exist so
unconditional love does not exist for
man it never has been no it never will
even your woman to a degree is going to
love you and I'm not saying her love
isn't pure I'm not saying her love is
impure but a woman's love is still based
on your ability to fix her problems to a
degree if you if a woman comes to you
and goes I have this issue and you go
can't fix it on a long if that happens
over and over and over and over again
she will fall out of love with you well
someone else will fix it someone else
will fix it so it's gonna love someone
else whereas
I'll be honest in my relationships I
don't go to women to solve my problems
I I go to them to be happy
I want them to be happy I want them to
make me smile I want to give me the
affection I want us to have fun together
I might want children yeah but I don't
go oh [__] I have this big [__]
problem at work and then a hey can you
help me never I don't go to them to fix
my right I fix all my own [__] so it's
it's completely different Paradigm we're
loved in completely different ways right
what do you look for in a girlfriend
like with more Traditional Values like
keeping the home nice yeah that sounds
nice and stuff like that and I I've
brought girls in the Stream that
um you had a nice girl on the other
night yeah some of the some of the girls
I bought a stream like they show those
qualities but
I get kind of bored like they're just
like they're there like they're smiling
and like let's go to dinner and they're
like okay and
then they're here like
like they're doing everything fine like
I'm sure they can clean and cook and
stuff like that but I'm like and then
after like two days I'm like oh wow this
is a shoe they're just like following
you around like where are we going like
what now I want to go yay yay I'm just
like he's just like shut up just shut up
like they're not doing anything wrong
but I don't know I I think I value
um maybe this will change man maybe it's
a maturity but I I like humor I would
like to be able to have like back and
forth like a little bit of cheeky danta
you need like a smarter girl to be
honest that's why I disagree with the
fresh and fit they're like oh I don't
care if she's dumb but I don't want a
dumb girl around like always hungry with
you there and like even I like smart
girls even the Tates where I mean I
don't know like you know the
intelligence of their girlfriends and
stuff but it seems like they're not like
no they're smart they are yeah they're
smart like they can have good
conversations yeah I mean well they
don't really I mean
they're they're not dumb but yeah like
my point is like if you're going out to
dinner and stuff if they really are just
kind of just sitting there
I'm not trying I'm not I'm not
pressuring you to answer it was the
environment of the war room because when
you're there with like 10 G's you got
Luke Belmar juice Justin Waller like for
all these people they're just being shot
yeah they're there like they don't don't
speak English that well yeah like for
you so they're just like yeah
okay mother like it's just stupid I mean
yeah they would go like do you want this
let's get the coffee like
sneak or you want coffee and
but I don't think they're stupid I think
they're educated
um yeah
like you have to challenge you need a
mental Challenge and I don't need a girl
that's a pain in the ass that's going to
challenge you in that way I mean
somebody that's gonna challenge you and
push you to be even smarter even better
even stronger or be able to keep up that
conversation and
and then laughter to me like with a dude
like it you can't make me laugh you
don't gotta no that that's crucial for
men men need to be able to do that but
women overall and the red pills feel
like they don't care about that they're
just kind of like a bang made they're
just there they smile and cook and then
they they you know but
I I wanna I wanna get like a sidekick
you know someone who's there you know
like uh a female robin to my Batman
so you know what you mean yeah and these
most of these girls are they're not real
they're like Batman's maid
I'm getting Alfred
I don't I don't you know does that make
sense yeah I know I know exactly you are
making sense okay it's tough to find
though dude I didn't meet one girl the
whole year I was at college that I would
even consider dating even in Florida
that you've been in Florida no not at
all try showing the game now they're
saying sneaker wants a dude
yeah I get bored like with this the the
complete submissiveness she's just there
smiling like I don't know I like
conversation each I wish to hell you
were a robot what's that wrong that's
the the Tate coffee Hour podcast when he
was talking about that stuff he was
saying like because they were having
this exact conversation and they were
saying like you want someone with more
intellect and whatnot and he was like I
wish she was they said you don't want a
robot and he said [__] I wish the hell
you were a robot no I I don't want that
no yeah I agree with you there
men love women because
we're idealistic in the idea everybody's
having gay Co in the chat yeah thanks a
lot Chad emails are actually very very
realistic with their love they're not
romantic men are far more romantic than
women are women I'll give an example now
bro you ask any man you can ask a
full-grown man about his you could say
listen your ex-girlfriend just died even
if you hadn't seen her for 15 years you
can be like ah I loved her you find a
[__] chick and say your ex-boyfriend
died and he's a [__] anyway they
don't care
I don't care it's true it's true bro
that women can be heartless people don't
and and any Jews at the top of his game
knows bro there's been times even I had
felt guilt there's been times I met a
chick and did it and we end up together
whatever and and sleeping together or
whatever whatever and she's around my
house and she's like hey look like
laughing at her ex just pouring his
[__] heart out bro it's crazy they're
[__] they can be that's just childish
emotionally unintelligent drama loving
[__]
you know I don't I don't I know women
that do that but they still will stalk
and see what their ex is up to from 20
years ago 10 years ago this guy from
five years ago I couldn't give up
females love drama they love drama if I
break up with somebody like I could give
a [__] the next day I don't care what
they're doing I'm not checking up on it
I I don't get it everyone in the chat's
calling me gay if I had a harem then of
course you need them to be compliant
submissive and the okay coffee but if
I'm gonna be if I'm gonna have one if
I'm gonna be an August one I want the
sidekick I want somebody that I can have
is it gay to have a conversation with
the girl you're in love with not at all
this this is how red pill you guys are
it's gay to talk to a girl the red pill
takes it too far sometimes I'd say
nobody I'm triggered for my chat right
now they can be they can be and I know
men aren't perfect I'm just saying
there's a degree of heartlessness that
women do possess people pretend they
don't but they really do have it on my
phone oh my God there's a big [__]
crack
[Music]